[Music]
syan Belisario opens up about how her
husband Patrick J Adams reacted to her
new film feed a project that hit close
to home did he help you at all yeah
perhaps even I think it was difficult
for him I think it was challenging he
said to me very early on in the process
you know was he met me you know right
after I wrote this film but he didn't
know me then then when he read it he
said first of all everything in this
that is you that is the illness that I
struggle with is very upsetting yeah and
I don't know if I really want to support
you being you know walking back into
yeah and then ultimately he said okay
you know but I just want to let you know
that I'm gonna hold your hand to the
fire and that when you walk back out of
this you know you're you're coming back
to me you're reinvesting in your health
I'm not gonna see you put yourself
through through this only to fall back
into it again so he was really
supportive in the way that he I think
was like you know really watching me I'm
really protective of me the 31 year old
actress also got candid about her feed
co-star Tom Felton's married Potter past
he was a Slytherin so if you were in a
house in Airy Potter oh my god
God Griffin doing Christian oh man I
wish I was in Gryffindor I am terrified
of being Slytherin yeah because I feel
like you know it's a house of ambition
and I was like probably gonna end up
there but I think probably I'm really
grateful yep that's what I said - it was
like she's a Ravenclaw learning
everything sensibility yet so my my
husband tries to joke with me cuz he
knows nothing about Harry Potter and
he's like you're a Hufflepuff him like
you don't even know what I mean you know
you can't say that you didn't know
[Music]